the talks were
constructive
we received a proposal from
ukraine to consider their
clearly formulated position on
inclusion in the treaty
these proposals will be considered in the
near future and reported to the president and
our response will be given due to
the fact that negotiations on the preparation of a
treaty on the neutrality of a non-nuclear
status of
ukraine  In Ukraine, the security guarantee is
moving into practice,
taking into account the destined course of today's meeting of the
principles of the
Ministry of Defense of the Russian
Federation
in order to increase mutual trust and
create the necessary conditions for
further negotiations and
achieve the ultimate goal of
agreeing to sign the expulsion of the wife from the
above agreement,
it was decided to radically
reduce military activity at times  in the
Kiev and Chernihiv direction,
we proceed from the fact that
relevant key decisions
will be made in Kiev and conditions must be created for
further normal work  I would also
like to address the representatives of
Ukraine and
call on Ukraine to strictly comply with the
Geneva Convention, including
with regard to the
humane treatment of prisoners of war, we
call for the elimination of the
practice of torture applied to our
Russian prisoners of war and
call for the Ukrainian
side to adopt an exhaustive  Measures to
eliminate this practice after
today's
[music]
meaningful conversation have been
agreed upon and we are proposing a decision on
which the meeting of heads of state is
possible simultaneously with the initialing of the
treaty and the Minister of Foreign Affairs, especially
since at the time of this initialing and
consideration of the details of the treaty, it is possible to
discuss various political
nuances and details such  Thus,
subject to quick work on the contract and
finding the required compromise, the
opportunity to make peace will become much
closer and in the first round, in addition to
whether he absorbed the Russian Federation knows his
vegan convention,
I’m somewhere rightly insanely  long and well,
out and said that you know it is also important for us
, because there is an e50 friend article
coquette
girlfriend princess spending the coquette I say about the
mother-in-law I will be an international
ucla this type of tees for a long time.
the contract can be counselors than we are, only to
ensure that his
Windis on other things and all parties get
used to the most and there will be complete peace on the
territory of Ukraine without seeing
any foreign built-in links,
you mait them and you still won’t be joe ben guarantor I
won’t
international
Ukraine won’t
to sign such a dollar and because
everyone emphasizes strongly the stevie danish
trend if every May it will be
such a type of his peaceful often just
summer your dishes if you meant such a
position for that and for that you yourself for
that I all parties will all accept such a
position  everything will mean punctuation of
guilt and d--vid a complete squeal and for the same
people the sayaks there are three three three and a half
million yaks, but behind the cordon mike
turned around to charge them from and to the house and
then launch these mechanisms
international and domestic and
international cinema is necessary  will be
held there at the implantation
decision to the actor of dollars on guarantees without
soldering falls and on the foot procedure from the
cob ca there will be a referendum on and to whom
everything  the giants of her ukraine to express their
position consider it for a long time still ready i of the
film and against you the song body will be and the
ratification by the parliament of ukraine and the
parliament of ukraine c the key is the one who
past him from
rome blunts the market being in order to contract diys
foot in the console blowing for us